hello everybody and
welcome to a new stream that I very
poorly prepared I have to be completely
honest I just arrived in the venue so
I've got these two amazing people
confuted it's just I guess there's one
person visible but I swear there's a
alright let's do that again
alright everybody this time with sound I
just arrived in the venue so this is not
gonna be the best stream but I'm here
with the ladies Niner and really rent
come out to help me out and make this an
actually decent stream hopefully I've
spent all day so far in the Botanical
Garden and going around alone and
nothing kind of worked as I planned
because I got I got lost in the trends
and took the wrong one but a different
one then was delayed and all kinds of
issues and eventually I almost ran late
for this but I'm here God and I'm like
low-key kind of tired and it's super hot
outside and I should stop bleeding and
fix this part yeah yeah animals close to
death they said yeah I swear this is not
my fault I turn up to the computer and
there was a dead hippo in the water I'm
gonna show that off later but first we
need some some coolers it's really not
going to get a chair no unfortunately
there may be dis on the side
right right yeah I mean I was doing the
same also in a lot of other streets I
think I think yeah this this booth was
never intended for so many people at the
same time so yeah it doesn't have that's
good yeah yeah I mean this is extremely
sad I gotta say the dyeing mechanics are
quite realistic because it does float oh
my gosh okay it's gonna change into
bones at some point I saw Oh God
so how do we get it's okay yeah yeah
you can check yeah you can check box to
get ready Cooper's coming with that
little oh oh that's going to take
in the briars I'm a little bit excited
actually to see what's going to happen
you can speed it up sure but also really
afraid that the other hippo is gonna die
too
I love how they walk on the water we all
float down here Thanks oh is the other
one yeah yeah also I missed it at least
I'd look like I'd look like they were
choosing a spot to die like running to
the other hippo like I could feel myself
dying right now
yeah this is honestly I know a lot of
streamers have got animals died and
escaped on their watch but I mean this
is I think no actually I know that first
I was really bad but this is all just
kind of because the park is really
broken from the get-go ya know as you
really need to as soon as you open a new
safe you need to fix it up prawns here
just kind of gave us a broken safe I
don't have to be completely honest and
everyone is like going in and just
checking out everything and not taking
care of the animals
right they might get a little bit too
much yeah they died a little bit too
much it would be nice if they yeah yeah
no definitely but you definitely need to
fix the pursuit up quite a bit once you
once you get it Oh
[Laughter]
118 a few famous there's ladylike
authority player you know I don't even
know what I'm doing I just I'm waiting
for the zookeeper to go over here
because I'm very curious wait I thought
that guy was going to yeah
all right there we go it looks like
we're gonna get a whole team here wait
they're leaving
maybe they can't reach it in the water
definitely if you click it oh that's
weird
it wasn't effect was it no I think it
was always yeah I'm gonna wait until
these these guys are oh my god I haven't
fixed nearly enough things in this point
alright so I need to get I'm gonna pause
the game before anything else yeah yeah
I need a lot of stuff yeah so I think
you need some fans but I'm just gonna
place
those enclosures are cool 18 years there
is a thing but it's turned off right now
are you kidding me yeah yeah so yeah a
whole bunch of pics for keepers and
probably cause you to makes like a take
place because this this party no no
focus it clearly understands dancing
takes it need those too many I mean
they're not as important I think it's
always maple and for some reason for
every stream that went wrong I think
it's always the Bears that start it and
then like as a as a Rube Goldberg
machine everything goes wrong from there
oh I needed to repair a conscious to it
like that I really need somebody to
repair and current we need more
mechanics in general interesting
this is yep that makes sense I guess god
this is okay I'm not gonna look at this
anymore I want to eat there I want to
keep the stream pg-13 this is a bit
graphic this is a Connie I can't but
that's because he is tagging your names
yeah yeah if you really want us to read
your chat messages then to tag my I keep
having to look over the microphone some
of the menus if you ever see me doing
this it's because there's a microphone
in front my face that's slightly out of
frame we have a bit yeah I'm gonna bill
there I'm gonna build a small graveyard
here I think we have some signs so this
is gonna be my first thing that I have
rebuilt Mother's Day I'm afraid yeah no
not pretty with like science in general
that you can put all kinds of stuff on
what do we build a great I think I think
we can use mulch honestly wait somewhere
in here oh that's a nature of course
yeah so was a really good guy that's my
Finder window it's a bit difficult to
get the scaling mind I'm not sure if a
hippo could fit them in this because
realistically the grave needs to be big
enough for a hippo right there are only
bones left I did it that oh I love throw
bottles of course yeah
where does ooh I swear I did not do that
as far as we know that will be some kind
of you know like the end of tape on it
so you have that like that below when
you starve if I'd like it's confronts
all night I think but we haven't seen it
yet but I think it will be like the
globe as you see a planet coaster but
then we will have the globe like the
continent and then we'll have like
different cameras at different
continents yeah so there definitely will
be
so I'm just gonna look for the signs oh
god that's a lot of signs actually I was
so this one is edible oh there's been
music says hi you know you're all doing
an amazing job also young America's who
looks pretty - yeah you know I do not
agree with this we also have somebody
else waving outside the booth everyone
so yeah let's get that 3d gizmo action
going
get some science here we had it's okay
I'm not gonna make a what's wrong oh
that's a really good point isn't it
maybe if I misspell anything we're gonna
change the color on that if I misspell
anyone anything let me know please
because this is all right let's see you
the chat
idea as well let's see
and so at the very least I think we can
get some new hippos that we have enough
caretakers now I don't think the hippos
have any choice in the matter I think if
I were a hippo I would not want to be in
the zoo but I think that was a lion
actually it was a lion oh yeah there we
go
so that is convenient you're not gonna
lie oh wow yeah you're right I don't
know it depends on the enemy yeah yeah
it depends on the animal that's this is
brown supers two dogs amazing yes if you
were here Tuesday - it wasn't
States it was like at least four
exhibitors casas impress so that was
like the most relaxing day fully but
it's not like super alright I think they
can picture a video anyway do we have
new fonts and you never actually use the
site is not much but it makes like you
want I don't I don't remember some of
these alright so I'm shaking I'm
checking it's a good little man seems
nice I think yesterday so don't let it
not like the key was to go away wait
that's really long or just ricotta too
yes it makes sense it works all right
now I don't think this is enough
something about a cross kind of makes
sense but I've no idea how to actually
do that well let's see if we can edit
these kinds of posts and sort of make it
into a cross that might be cool so let's
see we have posts yeah there we go
and I'm just gonna make this one
position snap and align to surface just
to make sure that it's aligned with
these oh and I need to have it as well
I'm just gonna turn this turn this sign
into a cross and then also these
textures these textures are honestly
they're really good then again this is
an Andhra colorable texture so it
definitely was but I decided to recolor
it that's a good question
no just the text oh yeah yeah oh yeah
they all right this is some weird grave
action it's not the nicest grave that
I've made no I've never made a grave and
I spoke what we could do at least is I
did see that there are statutes for
hippos yeah so I think I'm honestly just
just for the heck of it I think I'm just
gonna do some work work and stuff and
place a hippo statue on top of it yeah
oh yeah good points yeah I think from
now on I'm gonna like start building
more in pause mode because in a theme
park you know pretty much nothing that
really go wrong while you're building
unclosed but in a suit game you should
probably built with the game in postman
yeah oh yeah you want to see an unholy
abomination let's go it looks so happy
it's it's not very bitter for a grave I
think that's just still missing
somebody asks if grant plating besides
rock brass and other types an option
with autofill I'll look into that
I don't recall anything like that but I
do recall that there are some new
options but boundary highlighting we're
missing one name so other things is just
the same as in oh yeah we can't do that
oh no oh yeah we can auto penis is the
same as any planet poster I think yeah
automatically puts in different textures
dangers anymore is it
thank you that's that's oh no way it's
this guy again I've seen this exact
thing happen before
[Music]
yeah because they can just climb over
this this barrier yeah yeah that's a bit
just make sure
yeah there's someone running that make
sure the train is not coming oh they
just shot okay
I'm sorry guys I can't show you that I
can't show you that god I remember a
roller coaster second three wild the
tranquilizer helicopter that was like
one of my favorite things ever I don't
think that one's coming making a
comeback but then again I feel that
would be kind of inappropriate is there
going to be challenged more like a blank
oh no idea could you look at their
abandoned mineshafts and dungeons i I
don't think so
Oh actually I want to try what you were
doing Rudy tried this button yeah that's
so cool does anybody know this is in
planet coaster as well because I have no
idea like you can automatically go
through the menus without having to use
your mouth yeah I mean yeah this is what
we have German keyboard and this is
German key
[Laughter]
to find a rock that's like it's not a
Blanco
so that's a new feature that's quite
correct okay wow that's really useful if
you're just doing rock work and you want
to quickly switch up the road there's
also a lot of options for the right okay
and we do have some slightly smaller
works as well this is nice just gonna
basic let's go out of this and I'll try
to add some yeah
so what you do with the game where you
like it here well the great okay
actually I should check the biome here
biomes the temperance
looks mostly liquor or less a good name
okay that's not that close
I'm just gonna look at the foliage again
honestly I think m7 is just right now
just literally crying oh yeah yeah you
already was a few days ago I think yep
yeah the footage is really nice what is
this hi you look like I'm very curious I
do think it's just a single yeah it's a
single texture like infinite postive I
do think the texture is much more that's
also good and we got more different
shapes as well I don't know if all of
these robes actually grow on rocks
realistically I need to look into that
it looks beautiful
can we have a nap in the chat for our
dear hippos do it too soon too soon
like way too soon I wasn't even on time
here God
somebody's asking for my thoughts in a
certain game that I will not name yeah
let's call it the game that shall not be
named anyway many animals have breached
their habitats which is not very used
very very good I mean what's actually
happening oh these guys have been in
lockdown for a while so what else
looking ill oh yeah also you need to get
away with one wolf because constantly
fighting right so oh you bought them but
they're still the contain station right
okay yeah I'm lookin yeah so these guys
are fighting so I'm gonna move this guy
call this girl I'm sorry yeah where is
the trading center so then how do I
place a hippo in the echo you just go to
the animal training tab right and then
you just go to the second one yeah
animals mo teachers will exist
[Music]
but this one and the other one set the
zoo exactly known as that make sense
okay okay
return to habitat
you can't know because oh yeah but I
can't between oh I can return the
service yeah but you can't sell them
yeah so sent to Zoo and returned to
habitat what would be the difference
between that my outlook to other
habitats right new ones and we try and
just like the last one yes so I'm just
gonna introduce these guys right there
we go
what you do yeah what do I think of the
Amazon rainforest firing well that's
really terrible I was actually talking
about that at breakfast this morning as
I woke up and as soon as I woke up just
open my phone saw the rainforest then I
was awake but ya know it's really
terrible the fact that this has been
silenced but two weeks
[Music]
anyway what I'm actually gonna do in the
rest of this dream I think that oh god
we love even more okay I'm just gonna be
busy with you
but these guys these guys are moving out
should be fine the giant toad
overcrowded because they keep only oh my
god oh my god and you have to change the
defense to make it one side it because
they don't all right but yeah where do
your daughter I don't see them
yeah there's the adult as one of the you
know yes and yeah social space is the
perp well yeah well makes sense but I
can't release these guys into the wild
yet so I think that might be the case do
a sentence with the Turtles
I'm sorry I don't have the Infinity
Gauntlet I can't do that yeah
basically there will be sandbox and
career mode and the map that we're
currently playing is a bit of a weird
thing because it's technically a career
mode map but we're playing it on the
sandbox mode
but yeah there you guys have any ideas
of what else we should do in this stream
maybe build an enclosure yeah we should
set something that I actually haven't
done before
lady built an enclosure over here for if
you can try yeah just yeah right
this is already taken is yeah that's the
other thing
oh yeah yeah yeah this is quite small
this is the largest space console do
like in the middle there with the trees
this this one's already almost entirely
made yeah yeah it can't do too much with
them yeah let's just really make any
closer in there yeah the question is
what kind of animals do we have
available that we don't really have yet
let's see well I guess it's gonna be a
warthogs are empty ostriches yeah they
also go to live in one of us and sure
yeah I want to see the Snow Leopard
climb some rock work and there's the age
of animals correspond with in-game years
that's I'm I think so I'm not entirely
sure but I think so yeah it does it
definitely goes quite fast I don't think
we're gonna see those know that we're
flying rocks though no this I don't
think they can really I don't know just
to come in and check it if they have to
climbing now they don't have the need
but it
true actually a nice make a caller yeah
yeah alright so that one alone is not
enough
oh yeah outside as well and the terrain
isn't entirely great so that's something
like that except it needs less grass
that's right
more snow so let's just have a bunch of
snow over here well it takes a while to
the cooler water stay snow it's being a
bit iffy with their book work here oh of
course because it's not nearly cooler
makes sense yeah it is actually really
cool so I'm getting the snow as much as
I can so the snow is good I just need
more rocks to do now are we good
almost say they just don't like any
grass today yeah
where is that there we go all right you
got it and make it japanese gone in I
was actually thinking about that with
all of these plants you probably could
do a decent job they even have a cherry
tree
that's said they don't have the typical
Japanese pine trees like the Okada Comey
so that might be difficult
can you show us the black / gray iron
fence being such a natural fence
I'm surprised it isn't in Planet course
I believe it's forced into the Wrights
so but I assume you mean the barriers I
guess maybe this one
oh that's what it looks like anyway
doesn't work as well on the slope I
think because the texture is stays the
same but I guess that's the fence that
you were talking about there are ones to
my friends and then we've got all the
airlocks and doors and stuff to play
like this as well
I like how they snap to the events that
you have a place that's actually really
useful it's the worst
yeah and it's partly course Sarah keeps
doing giveaways and then there's also
Logitech on the other side you have a
stage that are quite loud as well yeah
yeah and we're also sitting next to
IGN's so those two guys were a IEM they
were just next door here we could really
you could probably see them from the
other streaming booth yeah so let's see
what we want to do with this cool I
actually I want to play around with some
other things too haven't seen up these
already ok so this one isn't actually
gonna prove top my spies or does it you
know it doesn't what else do we have
like snap I actually I haven't played
around with this too much so I know
might be interesting
and finally why are angles that make
sense and the length of course you can
actually make these really sure this is
really cool
the UK Germany yes 12 points for German
you finally got something yeah I'm sorry
you guys totally suck this depends yeah
I guess there's this idea we can just do
this hope I haven't seen it yet what a
studier the console oh yeah right
probably a console it's basically just
enabling you to play and kind of unlock
a streamable performance thing yeah
right you have two can play via any
device that is connected to start yeah
which is pretty cool actually
yeah but I think especially in Germany
the internet connection speed is not
really yet it's definitely not ready
right so this guy just took so much what
it's all about now like I don't know
with an actual gimble - yeah that I am
with Sean stream today we literally had
some guys dressed in a Deadpool costume
so hard but the microphone fell down oh
my god the camera you know at least at
least you could say they were in
character all right yeah
the fans just the left off chain fence
oh that's the that's the wooden logs
actually and then this one is the one
weight loss yeah
so yeah that's that oh and then we also
have changing and electric so that's
what all of your creditors etc you know
what I've always wanted to try though is
typically in real life series they'll
have like a little ditch and then a very
small fence so we don't have to like
look through glass or look over a big
fence but I'm not entirely sure of my my
ditch digging skills whether that'll be
animal proof
yeah it's a really good point
can you build a pool out of scenery
walls instead of fences we have we've
tried that I'd really have to be they
really have to be fences can you explain
how the no offenses work to you many of
you have to block the gap with objects
hold on that's the invisible fence yeah
do you haven't tried it yet yeah exactly
so they work pretty easily so what you
do is you build very normally habitat
wall uh-huh and then so it has to be
completely yeah that's okay look after
the car and then you just don't see it
but you still have to make walls so that
means the animals don't see the water
it's only for the game you noticing that
this works right it has to be a natural
water line so you can't just do the no
fence option and just hope that the
universe don't run but this is for the
sake of making these walkable enclosures
so no plans
it's basically invisible but it also
makes the existing it's only to make the
game
that is a habitat yeah also if you put
like for example terrain and you know so
let me know how much terrain is in
because else you would have to paint the
whole map yeah just kind of yeah there's
the no offense also like basically yeah
you can just use the whole fence and
combine it now because you don't need a
fence in the rocks okay so how do I do
this you just go to the North fence in
the menu right and then you just just
want to see the house real quick that's
nice
all right all rights to it sounds good
let's see I'm still seeing it oh wait
wait this is the no chance yeah they're
right yeah when you click on a fence it
starts building the same thing no you're
just take it act like the normal one
yeah I see that
oh yeah I'm i moved my way into the
rocks here that's not the best position
to be in
it's gonna be a bit difficult to connect
this because I've no idea where to
connect it to yeah it's nice yeah there
you go alright so good points say unless
gates okay what's wrong oh really yeah I
should be alright so now that habitat
should be completely fine right yeah so
I just want to add some windows in here
because obviously I don't want to have a
straight wall through most of the
enclosure can you use normal walls yeah
you basically have to use the new fence
to create a habitat and then you can use
normal walls to do like enclosure
it's totally it's totally doable you
don't need to use any of the barrier
anything hey they are only there to
create like for the game the info that
there is but animals have an interaction
with any object in the game so they
interact with everything and so when
they can't climb so my question was
actually also but I suppose this is true
the normal doesn't actually physically
existence a wall exactly animals they
can climb one that will then just climb
over here and yeah I will just they will
just yeah yeah makes sense so that's
actually quite useful and realistic I
suppose and I think if I'm gonna build a
shelter anywhere I should probably be in
here we need to keep track of the time
still have a decent amount of time to
build a decent in 20 minutes exactly so
I'm gonna build a shelter out of these
books I think that'll just be the
easiest way of going about this yeah
you definitely have shapes of rocks that
I think they intended me I built
shelters out of like these these flat
rocks there's no way they didn't intend
that which yes pretty much perfect
although these really flat ones I'm not
like a big fan of these look I know a
little bit unrealistic yeah yeah easily
that's true when they have some very
lengthy boys in here as well look at
that you could maybe use that like
foundation for a building or something
right as a fence
interesting how does the water behave
when you pour it into the terrain
betterment Blanco
I think pouring it into terrain is the
same as Blanco basically really the the
new thing is that you can build it
within enclosure walls and not just the
ring yeah yeah actually yeah that too
and maybe one thing to notice is that
you do have to do the terraforming
before you can't just do it as a bank or
put down the water and then just keep on
terraforming right yep conic I keep
pressing the wrong buttons but I swear
that's just because it is a weird German
keyboard that's the only you know that's
the only advantage that I had is the
yeah yeah right but the English version
so it's exactly providing me happy it's
a bad sign like good
can we see it here on the water actually
Germany yes and they are pretty proud of
that we go to the sound is muffled water
and yeah you can see underwater and it's
actually different depending on how to
clean the waters yeah at time of day it
is and which whether it is so it's super
cool and also you can even hear the
raindrops pouring down to the water when
you're below water it's so insane
I mean we all know how good design yeah
again yeah that's really cool people
keep always waiting here but I tried
showing that off in one of my earlier
screens as well yeah yeah yeah you
should go check that out really cool
some reason it bounced woo hoo isn't
working on this way well oh I can't I
can't move it alright yeah all right and
that's actually changed it to 8-under
that a little bit it's not the best
shelter so I should probably expand it a
bit you might burst
I'll see if this I can always build a
little house or something like that
somewhere you still have to put like
batting and
yeah actually what I love to see is I
don't know if you've seen it but the
water tea to be in like a mutt they get
to take a look at my school days just
yeah that's pretty cool yeah that's one
of the major ways for them to calm down
right yeah somebody's pulling some crazy
tricks in front of us
shout outs against the Tom yeah anything
else then animal you want to see in
flames ooh I feel like oh my God look at
my [ __ ] sweat on the table oh wow
can we move this already there was some
there's some giant t-rex's entering the
enclosure just now I'm calling this
place yeah yeah this this hall booth
looks like an animal enclosure well
three really so that's why um oh yeah
we'll see if that does I'm still not
entirely sure if I want to go for
ostriches or more folks in this place
but you said you can have them both
right yeah all right take care
yeah so do they have similar needs and
terrain as well Yeah right makes sense
so I don't think this shelter will be
quite enough I do want to have like a
separate shelter so you can like have
the warthogs and the ostriches have
their own little place
is that developing good layout and
choose Thursday they choose like when
they see if one is taking they won't
have another one yeah don't go together
so that's actually cool that they have
to go so I'm just gonna build a really
really simple wooden top here it's
nothing nothing really too interesting
but I'm just very curious to see what
pieces we have again because my memory
is not that great actually when it comes
to this oh we have air conditioning
units but I love it the change
how can you see if it's a great piece or
not that they only have the little grid
icon on the top of that oh there that's
great that's makes a whole UI so much
more yeah that's amazing
decorative strip Oh
so that's really to put on the walls for
instance yeah and I'm not entirely sure
I do want to go for a little of rustic
looking kind of building it could be
just a small wooden huts yeah you can
see how many pieces I really intended to
look like good show yeah yeah yeah
but gone there is just too much in your
keep track oh yeah there will probably
be more scenery I could also go for that
no no no it's just just a little wooden
huts I shouldn't go overboard there are
all these really cool building a tower
I'm just gonna build a small house for
the warthogs ends up building a
Victorian Alice Paul Farah is really
just a warthog habitats yeah that's what
it's always been supposed to do we don't
have that many like flexible wooden
pieces though we've got some of those
wooden clothes I could probably build
something with fence I'm just I'm gonna
need to filter stuff so roofs and floors
in one tab actually think that makes
sense
I know there were a lot of floors and
roofs that people and clinically used
interchangeably entities yeah I tended
to do so see we have some slick roofs of
course I think they'll be good for this
is a building object or whether works
with no they won't walk through it they
will avoid or klandermann or just move
over it depends on how high they are so
some bigger animals can step on them
while smaller ones must just climb but
if they can't they just walk around
right
I'm actually not used to building like
this normally I have the thing turned
off the thing that it automatically
stacks yeah there we go that and yeah
now I guess it's just time to build some
woodwork I think this is the right size
for the White House as well I can
definitely work with that where's that
wooden post that's I do like that the
icons are very similar or the same
yeah right even that is the same
actually yeah all right okay this thing
is nothing to this positions now I'm
also gonna get rid of that I am so glad
that the controls for this game are
pretty much the same as a memo all right
let's do some wooden frame work
see how that works before purposely
misspelling my name I love it thank you
there's this whole meme about
misspelling my name because yeah my full
name is silver I'm on the lam platen yet
which is ridiculously long so my youtube
name is actually just my full name but
abbreviated just taking some of the
first parts of each part of my date of
my name and putting them together but
yeah it's like it's people like do the
same thing that you know this meme about
Benedict Cumberbatch that his name is
like so recognizable that you can like
you can misspell it in any way you want
and people still recognize it as
Benedict Cumberbatch yeah my name is
like that I suppose
test me you know when you said no my
name is I was like already zoomed to
hook like okay Superman I guess yep I'm
trying to multi select piece at the same
time it shifted don't ask me why
interesting maybe maybe you can go into
settings yeah
game play and change them as well you
think so right yeah man just say that
you have copies pieces yeah yeah well
more or less actually see that I got
them crooked Oh little there a little
bit messed up but yeah they're generally
all right yeah so here we go so I'm just
gonna get some thanks for winning post
and actually I should have not done that
I should first just complete the whole
frame what am i doing you could just
also select with one good piece to
compete easier yeah all that I want
I like to surface there we go thank you
I probably after you get used to like
resetting all of this I things because
I've met order with my planet coaster
setting so much that I think I'm not
really used to the default settings
anymore and I want we want least to meet
where the pillars movie so that sounds
doable that honestly sounds doable but
I'm need to let you know alright again
alright oh it's too warm in here is it
this is my god
oh yeah good job because you got it you
sure - surely you didn't look that up
what is your thought on the difficulty
level - game I have to say it's
difficult to judge with this scenario
I'll also be completely honest I'm a
little bit annoyed by this map that we
got as streamers because it's it is
definitely a zoo where a lot needs to be
fixed up so if you're just starting off
with this industry you may don't know
too much what to do you can really
easily mess up everything and have all
the animals killed so this scenario in
particular might be a bit difficult to
get started with but wait I forgot about
these other tanks the whole thing
I actually no idea I have to
automatically select all of them at the
same time bit there we go anyway yeah
yeah so there we go
the gizmo who's not being reared anymore
please okay is that name French or Dutch
it's actually as from French don't know
exactly what the story is but my family
is gone how can I kind of get a straight
wooden post on it is yeah that's really
weird
I would I would kind of yeah like these
to be straight
I think that's straight anyway almost
that's probably a little bit off but
yeah I wonder what's up with that on all
of the posts in planet coaster
definitely stay straight yeah but yeah
so apparently it's from my great great
ancestors who moved from France to
Indonesia and then that whole family
stayed in Indonesia for a while and then
when Indonesia became independence they
moved to the Netherlands yeah there's a
there's a lot of people that moved from
amnesia to the Netherlands after they
became independence which is a political
kind of worms that I'm not going to open
but that's basically what my family
comes from yeah oh I need the bedding
though forgetting the most important
thing here how much okay 10 minutes yeah
yeah yeah whoo I do like that the grass
automatically goes away with
with the tomatoes time I can put down
pat like something the right we don't
really have any like old lights that you
could attach I guess this this is
actually just doable it's a bit fancy
for an animal shelter I suppose that it
probably shouldn't do that I was
thinking maybe a simple wooden light or
something but I know I really like yours
as well and I don't even have a
functional habitat yeah I'm not sure if
I'm gonna make it in the end
oh yeah these guys are gonna want to
know what time it is so I'm gonna put
this yeah
the object list is a bit limited it's
not too much I can play with here by oh
yeah oh this and this is really nice
bamboo as well I'm gonna be completely
honest I really didn't like the bamboo
and planets close to it but this is
really really beautiful yeah it would
this be temperate I guess ostriches
should be Savannah but warthogs I
suppose well either way just some simple
bushes can't go wrong with those I've
noticed also that a lot of these plants
do exist in multiple biomes if they do
in real life so that's good
not a big kind of that how that looks
I'd like them to be maybe small tree
next to it something like that but yeah
I really want some grunt probably next
to this so I'm just gonna switch to
temperance because I want that branch
Robby order it's not exclusive tabs so
you can actually click on multiple at
the same time and get the difference
yeah yeah that's actually much better
yeah yeah definitely in this case when
you want to mix different my own get
some smoke crunch shrubbery in there
this reminds me of evaru now it doesn't
look like pivara what are you saying
this look like I do not remember giving
you any permission to do this oh yeah
that's that's a fair I do like that
bamboo but I don't necessarily need it
but it looks awesome
there are just so many really beautiful
bushes in this in the 40 this time I'm
not going to go too overboard with the
foliage but I definitely one to have
more tags you can you can't see it
because of your a lot your extreme but
on there I mean
oh yeah right let me see
prego actually it makes more sense to
have us here anyway let's do that but
then you can see like maybe then we have
the lady fern again I'm sure you're
gonna place a lot of those yeah I need
to hurry up I know God oh yeah that's
true you're doing this all for me
that's that's the worst photo I really
need to get used to all of this crunch
already yeah it can make really good
forest floors things like this oh it's
floating oops
all right now I think it's funny time to
put some animals in here I think it
should already be okay right
ostriches and warthogs was the idea they
can fit any one in here habitat but okay
sure it's writing but this doesn't this
doesn't seem like a very nice yeah there
we go
yeah Tigers will probably escape from
this this is not a safe place I think
there's only there's only one warthog
left I said this is gonna be ostriches
we might put the warthogs in later but
oh this one's already 23 years old so I
think we're just gonna get ally and oh
good point no but that's the point I'm
getting are these so I can raise all
it's a good house
[Music]
[Music]
then I just have to wait for the trade
center to get these guys in here and
then we'll see in the meantime I can
already put some stuff yeah I know I
just bought them first I'm gonna look
into
oh really yeah well first I'm gonna make
sure that I've got you know stuff that
they want in the Oh hold on why does
this not work do we need to have them
for this oh yeah oops sorry that's my
bad do they want to forage I guess they
do right see if we can then well
technically if they're gonna for it
anyway that should probably do it closer
to you now actually I'm just gonna
happen for over here it's a nicer place
and I'm gonna give them a small beach
ball I think it's quite a sizable ball
but whatever they say oh yeah right yeah
because otherwise that otherwise you
can't switch it up right yeah and I
might actually just place this in the
bedding as well
and actually done this witness oh yeah
yeah yeah totally we'll get to that
where is the food and I'm just gonna go
for the launch ones because so far I
don't really see too much of a reason to
go for the small ones unless you really
know for sure that this is a small one
going to be enough and yeah that's all
right
do you need a signed sleeping placing if
you're using multiple animals in one
enclosure I don't think so I think I'll
just sleep wherever they want yeah but
I'm yeah I'm really curious to see how
they'll behave in that respect wait why
can't I sent these guys to the whale
that thought I did catch trade it's not
letting me release these guys yeah for
now I'm just gonna open up don't release
into the wild yet in this habitat and
[Music]
oh wait not centers ooh yeah there we go
that's a while the wheel has disappeared
in front of us let's speed up the
process because now I actually I have no
idea what terrain they need specifically
they definitely don't want to have this
tall grass I think but yeah let's just
click on it and see how they like it oh
there we go
me neither
the habit is not too bad actually oh and
actually the terrain is 100% terrible
all right yeah they need yeah what is
[Music]
that makes sense well let's see though
I've actually been wondering what does
this mean like it's also exciting
because it's all new so you don't want
do you like stupid thing you want to do
it right but then again like we're all
not experienced because we've just got
the game to like played it
I will do I will try to get nice yeah
that makes sense so that was a terrible
idea
all right already being placed back so
basically I think I just I just need to
put a big rock over here and then we
should be fine yeah yeah seen
opportunity let's go see any other
questions that we're missing a safari
right yes we can't actually built the
rides that's something that's not
available in this bill yet
[Music]
like the complete game we only know the
Train yeah I don't even know these are
integers between is but it's a deep idea
which is that only a few animals just
something stuff to it to show off yeah
it's not it's definitely not a game it's
not actually been wanting to change this
bit yeah there we go make the texture a
bit nicer it's going to be quite a
challenge to also balance the the soil
types that the animals need and what
actually looks good from a guest
perspective as well but yeah pretty much
anything where they can they will go for
it so we just tested that and if you
just pull away for example one little
thing they mean you know that so yeah I
really have to watch out
don't put trees too close yep well I
think I'm going
always needed yeah you meet the
invisible fence to get like the
enclosure finished you know but you
still need to build enough of all
terrain and so you can just have like a
water area where the animals that you
have in that enclosure comment are not
able to swim then you can use that as a
barrier so yeah it depends on the animal
and it depends but you really need the
invisible fence Yukon has like just an
open space with like yeah yeah what they
did there was you know to get it ready
and we have it in its table and honestly
there was not a single crash for any of
us yeah yeah it is so stable it does
what it does
every zoo is my community place it's
pretty stuff anyway yeah you have like
3,000 guests from her own roaming around
again Whoopi's lady yeah exactly yeah
and I think the final game which a lot
of people are starting to worry about
will have the same perspex
recommendations as planet ghosts as well
so the performance I believe should be
similar to planet coaster yeah so if you
can run planet coaster you should be
able to run fine but I'm done I think
yeah so yeah everybody watching my
stream I'd like to thank you very much
for watching
but we're gonna keep going sort it
actually yeah
the idea behind well this this whole
streaming setup here is that every
streamer starts a map over again so you
can't save because that's just not
available in this film but we figured
lady is gonna stream in the same room
after me so I might as well just not
close the game and give her the matter
so exactly so yeah yeah promise you guys
to read the chat
questions as possible if you can show it
on like I've seen a lot of questions
that we're just not able to show in
these builds so yeah yeah maybe we see
you there
and I also have a crazy so yeah if you
want to see us keep going with this ooh
you can move over to the lady signers
channel and yeah we're gonna take a
small break and set up the stream again
and then after that we'll be back bye
guys that beautiful thing there we go
you're getting a bit of a backstage view
here alright now we're really stopping